bom dia a todos trabalhando na educação
grande parte da minha vida am
trabalhei com o ambientalista o objetivo
do ambientalista o meu objetivo é criar
melhores condições de vida para
população para as pessoas e também
permitir uma melhor qualidade de vida a
uma instalação com os animais mas a
outra minha parte tem a ver com educação
com ser educador e o objetivo dessa
outra parte da viga é da área
habilidades promover a educação entre
pessoas para que as pessoas possam
proteger melhor o ambiente melhorar a
sua qualidade de vida
mas tudo isso começa com um passo de
cada vez
esta esta tartaruga aquino presentes
passo de cada vez
a cada mil nascimentos apenas uma ou
duas tartarugas chegam à idade adulta
morrem no caminho mas há sempre aquela
kan sobreviveu e daí ser muito
importante nós temos essa noção dos
nossos sonhos e darmos um passo de cada
vez
alguns mais apressados outros mais
lentamente
às vezes como diz o ditado quando dois
passos e quebra com a do espaço não está
com medo está a apanhar balanço é
preciso nós damos um passo de cada vez
paulo freire diz que ensinar não é
transmitir conhecimentos não chegar e
passar a palavra das pessoas fomentar
ideia é criar é essas possibilidades
para que as pessoas possam produzir o
seu conhecimento os seus a sua
construção do significado por todos nós
temos informação na nossa cabeça
todos nós queremos passar essa
informação e nessa troca de idéias nós
construímos significado e esse papel que
eu tenha sido para o papel dele
a dor e ambientalista tenta juntar essas
duas perspectivas
tudo começou nos anos 90 com a criação
da juventude ecológica angolana numa
altura em que ainda não havia eleições
mas nós os jovens já eram democráticos
tivemos eleições não correram muito bem
mas tivemos eleições
era numa altura com duas notas eram os
milionários
muitos de nós naquela altura fomos
milionárias e é muito significativo essa
questão do milionário trancamento nessa
altura nós fazíamos tudo sem dinheiro
agora não fazemos nada sem dinheiro e
isso tem um impacto bastante grande
nas metodologias nas abordagens de
educação ambiental que nós fazemos nos
dias de hoje são completamente
diferentes das suas passadas
esta fotografia de um cartão de
estudante do makarenko na altura via
aquilo que é o encaminhamento nós éramos
encaminhados para um curso eu acho que
eu fui desencaminhado porque fui fazer
um curso de electricidade que eu não
aparecia nada mas tive que fazer e
acabei o curso e depois tive que subir a
engenharia eletrônica que acabei por
desistir porque era o que eu queria
fazer
sou hoje percebo de sabores que eu dava
meu pai que está ali por exemplo hoje
tendo filhos é que sei que o fato é às
vezes as decisões que nós tomamos não
são as mais corretas na altura mas anos
mais tarde acho que os provocar esse
desencaminhamento ajudou um como um
trampolim que nós encontramos muitos
obstáculos na nossa vida e o importante
é quando encontramos obstáculos transpor
os obstáculos usar os obstáculos como
trampolins usar essas dificuldades que
nós encontramos no dia a dia para
podermos dar o salto e mais uma vez dar
um passo em frente
então essa época representou isso o
crescimento de uma organização meu
crescimento enquanto indivíduo numa
tentativa de educar os outros e educar
primeiro que não havia na altura a curso
na área do ambiente então era um
aprendizado contínuo anos depois volta
de 95 tivemos uma idéia criar o primeiro
programa de rádio ambiental em angola
chamado pelo fone verde um programa que
tem uma abordagem muito
fiquei num programa em directo quando as
coisas podiam ligar expor as suas ideias
e receber respostas na hora poderiam
escrever um ano mais tarde surgiu o
verdinho na altura não havia muito
emocionais fim de semana havia dois ou
três mas o verdinho surgiu como uma
iniciativa igualmente do partilhar
ideias e trocar informações de poder
informar as pessoas estavam muitos
informadas e uma das informações que
vocês podem fazer trabalho em casa
procure a nota de 10 coisas antigas
felizmente saiu de circulação e vão ver
o animal está lá lá diz palanca negra
gigante o palanca negra mas na realidade
um burro do mato é capaz de transmitir
uma ideia de quem pôs o animal lá mas
depois do fundo verde que era um
programa na luanda antena comercial uma
rádio para quem nós temos muito carinho
fomos para a rádio nacional de angola e
criamos um canal verde era a mesma
perspectiva
o programa começou em directo um ano
depois fizemos o primeiro programa onde
se juntou à rádio nacional de angola no
antena comercial indireto transmitindo
simultaneamente para falar do que o
desenvolvimento sustentável
ninguém sabia o que era isso então foi
com essas idéias criando essas idéias e
partilhando e juntando esforços de
rádios como que completa é que
conseguimos transmitir essa idéia mais
uma vez ultrapassamos alguns obstáculos
e demos mais um passo em frente e depois
porque vivíamos do voluntariado nós
decidimos arranjar formas de angariar
jovens para trabalhar na organização
fazemos palestras conversávamos
brincávamos fazemos festas carnavais
ecológicos não era um bananal é o mesmo
cara vai bons então criamos este
concurso conhecer para conservar terão
concursos com institutos médios e para
universitários do ano inicialmente com
os pneus para três províncias
nessa altura em 98 havia no ano imaginem
20 institutos médios entre
universitários
agora já não agora existem 300 claro que
a abordagem utilizada para a definição
desse programa foi diferente e mais uma
vez
motivamos as escolas não tivemos os
professores
o vencedor das olimpíadas do ambiente
eram um concurso que demorava um ano
inteiro um ano letivo inteiro ganhava
uma bolsa de estudo e formamos então
alguns jovens não foram todos na área do
ambiente claro que não era forçar espera
incutir o bichinho do anc e aí mais uma
vez uma abordagem diferente temos que
educar
nós temos que conhecer para poder
confirmar porque nós não sabemos se nós
não conhecemos como vamos conservar como
é que sabemos que a nossa atitude é mais
correta então és lema conhecer para
conservar surgiu neste âmbito dar
informações aos jovens e aos professores
como resultado dessa trajetória toda dez
anos mais tarde em 2002 dois anos mais
tarde a criação da organização vê lá em
cima o prêmio global 500
é um prêmio foi dado pelo programa das
nações unidas para o ambiente da
juventude ecológica angolana como a
melhor organização juvenil do ano 2002
devido ao seu esforço de educação
ambiental
ficamos felizes porque de fato que
estava ser reconhecido lá fora cá dentro
não diziam as pessoas deixem lá dentro
do ambiente um ambiente não enche
barriga não 6 em jornal né
mas tem uma parabólica visita às vezes
mais às vezes menos mas aí está aí está
presente e portanto durante esse período
fui aprendendo fazendo curso de
jornalismo ambiental curso de educação
ambiental porque no discurso mas sinal é
chegada a hora de dar mais um passo em
frente não vou cair ao chão estou atento
e esse passo em frente pois é eu não
consigo encontrar essa educação aqui vou
sair a bola sair foi para a áfrica soou
trabalhar com o programa original de
educação ambiental
quando trabalhei com vários países da
sadc fazendo uma introduzindo materiais
fazendo palestras
eu tenho que aprofundar mais
conhecimento passo a minha vida toda a
produzir materiais seja pra rádio
jornais revistas materiais de apoio à
aprendizagem têm que perceber melhor
como é que isso funciona como é que as
pessoas se adaptam esses materiais como
é que elas percebem como é que como é
que nós geramos o conhecimento e foi
assim que embarcam em uma jornada longa
de teoria da educação que receberam um
cadinho mais as teorias neoliberais e as
teorias do construtivismo social que me
ajudaram a moldar o que eu sou hoje como
é que eu penso e como é que eu
desenvolvo as idéias e aí produzir este
livro desenvolvimento e adaptação do uso
de materiais de apoio à aprendizagem foi
feito igualmente em inglês para a região
e fizemos vários workshops é um livro
que demorou dois anos a fazer porque era
trocar idéias sempre um sentimento de
que nós não somos o dono do do
conhecimento o dono do poder temos que
partilhar essa informação e na partilha
de informação que geramos o conhecimento
e todos esses trabalhos foram sendo
desenvolvidos sempre com várias pessoas
tanto a ideia o dia surge de uma mas
partilhavam sempre com outras
depois resolvi voltar para angola e
então pra onde eu fui e vou por aqui o
casaco foi o governo pró governo as
coisas um bocado mais formais
eu não sou muito de furto de formalismos
mas fui obrigado a pôr o casaco nunca
gravata recusei sempre a gravata porque
fui contratado pelas idéias pensou e não
pela forma como como visto claro que
fizesse aquilo que é que seria melhor né
então meu primeiro trabalho foi definir
e elaborar uma estratégia para a
biodiversidade em angola ao longo desses
anos eu descobri que nós no país somos
muito bom sem estratégia sem política
sem documentos temos documentos
magníficos dar o passo em frente e um
passo na implementação é um caso mais
difícil mas tem aquele bichinho estava
formado em educação ambiental o meu pai
muito orgulhoso de mim
finalmente o filho formoso é e eu também
muito orgulhoso porque estava a
desenvolver coisas agora com o caso mais
do conhecimento humano caso mais de
experiência é então tava no governo isso
vamos continuar a estratégia nós vamos
fazer educação ambiental novamente
produzimos um kit de educação ambiental
com vários temas mas foi o que foi feito
de forma de frente e isto é os
professores diziam não adianta ter o
livro que depois não consiga preparar os
materiais
então foi com os materiais preparados
fichas postou suas fichas com os alunos
cds com apresentações para eles fazerem
e portanto correu muito bem essa
esse processo é essa a transmissão do
conhecimento a nível do governo mas
senti na preso e precisava de fazer
outras coisas então que eu fiz
tirei o casaco
obrigado ela quer fazer perguntas já diz
que não há perguntas aqui então no time
alguns projetos sempre na companhia de
educação ambiental tentado perceber a
importância do contexto tentando
perceber como é que nós podemos
partilhar ideias como podemos construir
outras idéias para que as pessoas
protejam ambiente tão como amigo michel
moraes neste projecto das tartarugas
marinhas onde os projetos com mais
sucesso no nosso país produzimos um
livro chamado tartaruga que era uma
coleção de histórias recolhidas em
escolas fizemos concursos as crianças
desenharam e fizeram história
então fui recolher essa história e o que
acontece quando temos histórias era
facadas matanças era era um desastre
eram histórias que tinham um fio mas
eram muito violentas
então realizar porque as crianças estão
a escrever histórias de violência da
violência organizada é a informação que
nós passávamos vocês os principais estão
a matar as tartarugas estão sempre nas
lendas são as velas dos barcos
aquilo que nós transmitimos foi o que
recebemos de volta mais uma lição que
aprendemos aqui como é que nós podemos
moldar as pessoas partilhar construir um
conhecimento mais uma forma que as
pessoas possam ajudar a proteger melhor
o ambiente que de uma forma mais
positiva e mudarmos um caso essa
abordagem fizemos teatro um teatro era
gravado com o cds mas o grupo de teatro
e ia para falar com as comunidades estar
mais próximo das comunidades e depois um
projeto que a palanca negra gigante é um
outro projeto espetacular nosso país
onde infelizmente só temos sem palavras
e há muito esforço para ser feita a
educação ambiental é um aspecto muito
importante que nós temos estado a
desenvolver mais uma vez pedindo
histórias para crianças porque estamos
sempre aquela vamos pôr os adultos vamos
com as crianças é que vamos temos
queremos fazer tudo o mais importante
mais uma vez e continuar a dar esse
passo em frente e esse passo em frente é
feito com várias iniciativas com várias
idéias
compartilha várias pessoas e uma idéia
que eu tive há cerca de dois anos foi
produzir um livro aliás antes de
produzir livro é discutir com um fiz uns
poemas com meu filho e decide não acho
que é importante partilhar essa
informação com as crianças do ponto de
vista de poesia porque ajuda a divulgar
a e através da rima as crianças aprendem
mais então foi feito este ano
este livro mas o mais importante de tudo
enquanto ser humano é que nós nós temos
a capacidade de pensar
somos racionais às vezes nem tanto
somos capazes de imaginar coisas somos
capazes de criar somos capazes de sonhar
às vezes com pesadelos no tranco mas é
possível nós desenvolvermos um bocadinho
mais do que tem um que tem caracterizado
anip só aumenta e algumas pessoas que me
rodeiam porque de vez em quando olho
para trás para ver estou sozinho e não
estou sozinha essa capacidade do
kamaliya essa capacidade de nós nos
adaptarmos aos diferentes contextos nos
adaptarmos às diferentes dificuldades e
podemos usar os abismos os precipícios
essas dificuldades para dar um passo em
frente muito obrigado
olha a cantar